we're familiar with these questions so
what we're aiming to develop right now
come in what we're aiming to do right
now is to develop fluency fluency you
know a fluency is right like you know
language fluency is the difference
between having to think consciously
about what you're going to say versus
not need to devote conscious thought to
it just being able to speak just like
that without having to concentrate right
so we want to develop 13 speeds with
regard to these kinds of questions I put
one out which is already in question
three because I think we should wanted
to you guys are fine with and southern
what was in your suit knowledgeable foot
so this is from memory its 3G okay
so let's really quickly run through it
together and make sure we've got the
right practices suggestion what do you
guys reckon we should do first tip it's
okay
I have choice number one which is to
move everything over to one side or the
other right be listening the quality
right and which one sold do you think I
should go to the left on the right
probably left right probably left that
would make sense okay
I can barely see over to the left or or
alternatively there's another suggestion
in order to give me another suggestion
I'm just saying what's better than I
just want other ways I could expect okay
so I could do some simplification so
falsification before I do that okay now
just looking at this do either of these
seem better than the other
hmm what do I pick it up why do you
think that is
yeah sure okay so I think that's
probably right if you have a look at
these two terms in the brackets here if
they were equivalent then there's going
to be a clear benefit to actually
transfer everything to one side
right because expanding is actually
increasingly out of work when I look at
this my instinct at least is to expand
first though I think it's fine if you
wanted to do it the other way let's all
for the sake of consistency it's there
so what do we got everything up the key
thing of course with inequalities is to
watch out for your negatives and all
your double negatives where they pop up
so here we're just going to get 8 minus
4x
that's pretty standard what are we
getting over here who wants to tell me
what big space you need some doesn't say
anything Yeah Yeah right now what do you
do pressure all right I can collect my
like terms there and then I can bring
everything over to one side as was
originally suggested clearly we're gonna
have to do eventually so I got my 16
minus 4 x over here okay suggestions now
yeah okay so generally we want to phrase
the X's on the left-hand side which is
what we're sky implied before and all
about numbers on the other side so at
this point because we I've done these
questions thousands of times I'm gonna
do the both simultaneously but if you're
not too sure about it it's worth doing
it over two steps not like me to say to
you both sides so I'm gonna subtract 2x
from both sides subtract 2x that's gonna
give me a negative 6 section over there
and I'm going to subtract 16 from both
sides as well come in
would you take a single shot today but
give a warning at least alright were
just don't you miss to track these
sixteenth birth signs which leaves us
with negative tweet three or right side
okay that's a bit awkward just check
your numbers because you know we kind of
sometimes expect numbers to be nice and
neat by the end does it check out were
there any numerical errors looks pretty
okay to me so now I just need to do by
I'll divide by negative six no sense in
doing it twice because I'm dividing by a
negative number the the direction of the
inequality is going to bring like so 23
on six and we're done finished okay so a
couple of things I would look at this
and being that it's linear period it's
linear okay which is all the kinds of
questions we even have a look at you
kind of have an advantage which is that
if you have gone through all of this and
everything's been fine you actually
don't need to check your answer ok
because it's linear I'll let you ever
think about why that is okay so okay
however if what I had up here was
something else right if it involved
polynomials of some kind like squares or
cubics right and I had to you know if I
did something tricky like multiply by
the square or something or square both
sides then you've got to take this
answer and you have to make sure it
actually satisfies your first slide okay
I'm just making that as a side note you
wanted to do that in this kind of case
because then the knee art but there's
your answer
make sure you do it even though this
question doesn't ask us to I'm just
going to fool lay the questions say
graph this on a number line here's a
number line now being that it's a
one-dimensional inequality mm-hmm it's
an inequality if only one variable right
that's why I have a one-dimensional
number line this is not going to go on a
plane right so this is going to be an
x-axis right on a number line one of the
important kinds of numbers you're gonna
prime it zero there is the most
important and then whichever other
values are relevant to inequality okay
so
23 on 6 I can just stick it there and
that's enough I don't need to put any
other points on there ok now it's less
than okay and it's not inclusive so what
should i do on the boundary it should be
an opening or a hollow circle like so
okay great question I'm going to
encourage you i'll stop short of saying
you have to but I'm going to encourage
you to put the circle right on the line
that means your circle needs to be big
enough to do that and then you'll like
that corresponds to that should also be
on the number line like so okay I'm
going to strongly recommend against
doing something like this for instance
it's a really bad idea now let me
suggest to you why is it that often
people did this okay the main reason is
because well if you don't want to spend
the time or if your pens not very good
you don't have do more the big declines
it's really hard if you do this right
here's your double line here's your
point and then there's your inequality
your region right and it's very hard to
see you can see that's hard to see right
and obviously like it's even easier with
the WIPO marker with a pencil it can be
quite hard right so that's why I had to
go and make it really thick okay okay
it's just to me not just for an
arbitrary reason but for a mathematical
reason why like this red don't let this
be a bad way to go about it yeah yeah so
you're actually making a statement right
when I'm without lifted off the axis I'm
now going into this is why a highlighter
I'm going into a second dimension which
is actually something completely
different right the whole point of this
is that there is one dimension I can
only go back and forth is lit up down
here
okay it's not something like safe yes
right which has two dimensions so that's
why you're on a Cartesian plane okay I
think that's worth taking the extra one
and a half seconds to just draw in a big
error and like make it on the number
line okay